the term sustainability I have a slight
issue with and there are many others
that have a similar issue with that term
Richard plunge at Columbia often says if
you ask 10 scientist 10 scientists what
sustainability means you'll get 10
separate and different answers bill
McDonagh also doesn't like the term
sustainability he thinks it's it's it's
not provocative enough it doesn't it's a
little bit to status quo when I think of
sustainability I think of baseball but
not really good baseball I think of a
team like the Chicago Cubs a team that
is sustaining itself the team that can
play you know at in the major leagues
but it doesn't really win any games
doesn't win so much doesn't evolve
doesn't change doesn't have too many
heroes is not a breathing growing
constantly nurturing beautiful organism
it's just kind of a group that gets by
it gets by to the next game in the next
game in the next game and it's it's not
enough I mean if you think of the new
york yankees it's a team that is
evolving growing powerful nurturing
intelligent filled with heroes it's a
kind of a winning a strikingly winning
team and and and and you would never
associate the New York Yankees with
being a sustainable baseball team so I
would think that if we're going to call
a movement sustainability it's it's it's
a little too dry so I think the choice
that I would often use is
socio-ecological and yes the mouthful
but I think it describes the problem in
two major sectors one it's about social
justice and the policies associated with
it and two it's about ecological science
because if these are big problems that
we're trying to answer we need to look
to some specific sets of science that
could help us solve them and I don't
think a term like sustainability does
that so well it's more of a philosophy
as well as a science as well as a kind
of attitude and its really an umbrella
for too much while the ecology is a very
specific science that looks at areas in
the landscape looks at flora and fauna
and makes makes decisions or has some
seriously
search and proposals and some positions
that are much clearer answers and
socio-ecological the terms mixed
together allows you to accept the fact
that it science is never going to be the
answer science is not a silver bullet
that you'll you'll need human activity
and the kind of culture associated with
how we live on this earth and the
government's that work with us to accept
that change is going to happen but it's
going to happen through through through
many different characters and actors and
agents working together and so socio
socio ecological design would describe
the field that I work